oh my god your new song my legs are
brought to you by your song I've been
squatting all week do i yes don't show
up you know Oh dad let me throw this
down you looks okay hold on so we've got
I feel like we got the little Bo memo no
I mean your this song is fire look at
you one that grabbed me last year and
you're like I got to come back with a
hit and you gave us a smash thank you so
much thank you I definitely definitely
made me work harder for sure okay for
the performance tonight I know you have
a whole gaggle of ladies with you what
can we expect it's um it's a futuristic
to skip watch it's probably the way I
could only describe it it's yeah it's
just fun like basically what I want to
do with these videos and what I want to
do and my music is just to have fun with
it I want people to do exactly what you
were doing is got burned down and do
squats and jump up and just dance and
you know it just I wanted to be so
carefree it's honest but it's it's you
know not taking itself too seriously and
I think that's exactly what I want to do
tell me about this fashion you're insane
always but who made this
this is Miu Miu tell me a secret about
this dress is their secret anywhere oh
I've got secrets hiding so many secrets
I normally hide secrets in might have
and now that the has out you're a blonde
two blondes have more fun and yes I'm
having a lot of fun it's also like two
tones so I'm still and I'm like riding
the half blonde wave is the song a good
representation of what's gonna be on
this new album yeah it's definitely it's
got lots of the whole record has a theme
going through it it's very disco
inspired 80s inspired that's fun you're
gonna have a good time okay who did that
who broke your heart though is my
question for this song but it's like
don't you call me now No
hoping that girl 180 baby I think it's
more like a metaphor I feel like I like
to use metaphors and songs more for like
my own privacy I suppose it's a good
songwriter date tonight my day is my
boyfriend I guess she's right behind you
so handsome you guys I'm racing on
Hudson right
[Music]